[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
áfrica siete días en france 24 este es
un magacín informativo 100 dedicado al
continente africano
yo soy liviana valència aquí damos una
mirada en profundidad a los hechos de
actualidad de la semana en la cuna de la
humanidad
el primer ministro libio reconocido
internacionalmente fallece al sarraj
anunció que desea dejar el cargo a más
tardar en octubre y traspasar el poder a
un sucesor la decisión podría alimentar
tensiones políticas en libia en medio de
nuevos esfuerzos para encontrar una
solución política al conflicto
en etiopía el lago más grande del país
está en peligro por la proliferación del
jacinto de agua una planta invasora que
está impidiendo la reproducción de los
peces y generando accidentes entre los
pescadores la crisis del coi 19 ha
ralentizado las labores de limpieza
tenemos para ustedes música que nos
llega desde el soto donde el cantante
morena le daba se posiciona como la
revelación de la música fusión este
antiguo pastor ahora recorre los
escenarios del mundo dejando en alto el
nombre de su pequeño país
iniciamos entonces con la información en
áfrica siete días porque el líder del
gobierno de ecuador nacional de libia
reconocido por la onu fai es al sarraj
anunció su deseo de dejar el cargo y
entregar el poder a una nueva
administración antes de finales de
octubre en un nuevo esfuerzo para
encontrar una solución política al
conflicto continuo que se vive en este
país del norte del continente
una salida en una situación frágil
fallece al cerrar anunció su intención
de renunciar como primer ministro del
gobierno de acuerdo nacional reconocido
por la onu y con base en trípoli
declaró mi sincero deseo de entregar mis
funciones a una próxima autoridad
ejecutiva a más tardar a finales de
octubre
a principios de mes las facciones
rivales de libia acordaron celebrar
elecciones y formar un nuevo gobierno
dentro de los próximos 18 meses en un
discurso televisado al ser expuso eso
como ejemplo de los progresos en los
esfuerzos para unificar el país pero
advirtió las dificultades para lograr
ese objetivo los coreanos en una casilla
según usted el panorama político y
social ha estado y sigue polarizado esto
derivó en que todos los intentos de
llegar a una solución pacífica que nos
permita acabar con el derramamiento de
sangre y proteger nuestra fibra nacional
que amenaza con descargarse aún más sean
tediosos y extremadamente difíciles
el deterioro de las condiciones de vida
como resultado de la guerra civil ha
llevado a protestas en ciudades
controladas por ambos bandos en las
últimas semanas los disturbios ya habían
causado tensión dentro del gn a antes de
que al cerrarse anunciara su intención
de irse las protestas provocaron que el
gobierno del este a línea do con el
comandante jalifa haftar renunciara el
domingo ambos hechos complican las cosas
para la onu que ha estado mediando en
los últimos diálogos entre las dos
partes en un intento por liberar a libia
de la agitación por la que ha estado
pasando desde el levantamiento de 2011
hablamos ahora de temas ambientales
porque el lago tana el más grande de
etiopía está en peligro por una planta
invasora que se propaga año tras año el
jacinto de agua tendrá el impacto
ambiental y económico que genera las
autoridades y las comunidades tratan de
luchar contra esta multiplicación de
esta planta que puede duplicarse cada
dos semanas pero la pandemia de ccoo y
19 ralentizó las actividades que van a
tener lugar antes de la temporada de
lluvias
esta gruesa alfombra verde cubre 190
kilómetros de costa alrededor del lago
tana en el noroeste de etiopía al
absorber grandes cantidades de agua era
a cinto le quita espacio al lago más
grande del país un medio de vida para
muchos pescadores
año tras año los peces desaparecen el
jacinto de agua impide su reproducción y
sofoca a los ejemplares adultos en este
pueblo más de la mitad de los pescadores
se han ido antes de la aparición del
jacinto de agua una red podría contener
hasta 30 peces ahora sucede que no
pescamos nada si podemos hacerlo
capturamos tres o cuatro peces dos
millones de personas dependen
económicamente del lago tana la
agricultura se hace imposible en algunos
lugares si bien algunas máquinas
detienen la planta la erradicación
manual por parte de los habitantes del
lugar sigue siendo la principal solución
empleada pero las autoridades tardan en
pagar el dinero prometido en
compensación por estos esfuerzos si no
luchamos por el lago tana por quien
lucharemos si perdemos la tana no nos
quedará nada escuchamos muchos rumores
de que no nos beneficiamos del dinero de
la subvención el dinero debe pagarse
correctamente la agencia gubernamental
dedicada a la protección del lago está
preocupada por la falta de recursos
asignados para combatir el jacinto de
agua que podría llegar a la gran presa
etíope en el niño azul
luz creemos que ya hay muchas semillas
allí primero podría reducir su capacidad
en términos de volumen de agua además de
golpear las turbinas podría
paralizar por completo del sistema
eléctrico entonces luchar contra el
jacinto de agua es como salvar la presa
del renacimiento hacia un metal de club
en la universidad va a ayudar los
investigadores están experimentando con
soluciones alternativas están
convencidos de que los gorgojos podrían
resolver el problema a largo plazo
los adultos dañan la parte externa de la
planta mientras que las larvas se
alimentan principalmente de la parte
interna de la planta entonces si estas
hojas se dañan o se comen ralentiza el
proceso de fotosíntesis del crecimiento
y la tasa de reproducción por el jacinto
de agua actualmente cubre un área
alrededor de 1000 hectáreas pero para el
final de la temporada de lluvias en
septiembre este número podría
multiplicarse por 5
en todo el continente están surgiendo
estudios de animación con el objetivo de
producir contenido de alta calidad pero
la falta de recursos genera la fuga de
muchos jóvenes directores del continente
a pesar de esos obstáculos en todo uno
de los primeros estudios de animación
del país sueña en grande e intenta
abrirse camino en el mundo del cine
animado todavía dominado principalmente
por empresas occidentales
me afectó mucho
el fugado de un extremo o tu afición que
yo le puse
este es el ambiente en uno de los
primeros estudios de animación de togo
en tres años el director y cofundador de
arucas ha construido una sólida
reputación
es el director a quien los escritores y
productores como yo llaman para
proyectos cinematográficos y series de
animación porque en cuanto a técnica de
animación boris es realmente un
referente en todo
con varios cortometrajes en su hoja de
vida boris pad en un lucha por cambiar
la perspectiva del espectador
no no
i
o sé que le dicen y le sabemos que los
dibujos animados pueden transmitir
muchos mensajes hoy sabemos que todos
tienen teléfonos inteligentes queremos
usar esto para llegar a más personas y
la animación es mejor que el cine
clásico ofrece más posibilidades pero
debido a la falta de escuelas de
animación en todos los jóvenes son
formados dentro del estudio
estamos en el proceso de descubrir
personas que no sabían que eran
competentes en estas áreas todos los
escenarios de los dibujos animados están
inspirados en las ricas y diversas
culturas del universo africano muy a
menudo explotados por el colonialismo
occidental la mayoría de las veces
consumimos lo que viene del exterior
historias occidentales pero no las
historias de áfrica en ese sentido
abogamos por difundir el mensaje
africano los valores africanos en los
viejos tiempos eran los griots quienes
contaban las historias hoy es un estudio
de animación el que cuenta la historia
aunque las tradiciones podrían
desaparecer con la omnipresencia de lo
digital
la animación conecta mágicamente con las
nuevas generaciones y las llevan
sutilmente a la fuente el cine animado a
la reconquista de su historia
hablamos ahora de literatura quién
áfrica siete días porque el escritor
cantante y dramaturgo lasa los ramos
está lanzando al mercado su libro
titulado en mi piel un relato sobre su
historia de vida que refleja los retos
que la sociedad le impone a los
africanos de la diáspora en américa
latina
[Música]
lázaro nació en salvador de bahía en
brasilia reconocido por sus trabajos
musicales y actorales donde promueve la
identidad de la generaciones de
ascendencia africana en su país en mi
piel es un libro escrito desde el poder
de la identificación y desde reflexiones
personales del autor que conectan desde
el corazón con miles de lectores en
varios países del continente desde río
de janeiro lázaro nos contó cuál es la
importancia de este relato para los
afrodescendientes de la región
bueno puedo responder esa pregunta de
dos maneras la manera más corta es con
una frase que se convirtió en un cliché
y es decir que este libro en la diáspora
latinoamericana es importante para
conocer nuestro pasado y así construir
un nuevo futuro esa es la respuesta
breve sin embargo me voy a alargar un
poco porque este libro me ayudó a mí
mismo a descubrir muchas cosas no a
gusto preocupen de mí
lo escribí a lo largo de diez años en
una búsqueda para comprender mi
identidad pero es una identidad que no
se describe apenas por lázaro como
individuo se describe también por la
colectividad donde él vive esa
colectividad brasileña que me dio varias
respuestas y ahora tengo la oportunidad
de llegar a otros oídos corazones y
mentes y esto es muy importante porque
la gente termina distanciándose a causa
de la geografía y no por conocer
nuestras historias esas grandes
historias y también las historias
individuales este libro es una
provocación para que iniciemos una
conversación para conocernos un poco más
para identificar esas cosas que nos
hacen iguales y también las que nos
diferencian más aún teniendo una misma
raíz ancestral esa raíz que puede ser un
norte y al mismo tiempo puede hacer
mucha falta si no aprendemos a valorarla
y a conocerla y que es construida día
tras día cada vez que alguien se conecta
por medio de un libro o de una
conversación entonces esa es mi
expectativa que podamos conectarnos que
podamos conocernos y construir un futuro
no repitiendo nuestro pasado para las
esposas con ese y construir un futuro no
repitiendo el su pasado
y finalizamos con música que nos llega
desde el eso donde el cantante morena
lira daba se destaca como la nueva
estrella en ascenso el mezcla música
electrónica bailable con reggae y hip
hop veamos la historia
morena le daba solía ser un pastor en
lesotho pero en los últimos años se ha
convertido en artista incluso ha actuado
en europa y ahora le muestra a sus
viejos amigos algunos de sus conciertos
en su teléfono celular
me hice conciertos en el extranjero
participé en grandes festivales en
francia en londres y en otros lugares
fue muy interesante tocar en otro lugar
y ver el resultado que se obtiene vino
materializase
[Música]
miraba mezcla su música electrónica y
bailable
hop su más reciente álbum fue grabado en
más en la capital
[Música]
realmente intentamos identificar a los
artistas que mejor representan a lesotho
y su diversidad y morena leerá va se
destaca entre las multitudes en escena
narra historias tradicionales sobre la
música contemporánea el país
desdoblar muse hay mucha música a
nuestro alrededor pero morena le daba
logró mezclar nuestra cultura local y la
cultura vaso tos con sonidos
electrónicos para conseguir un sonido
moderno amor dental de soto es una de
las naciones africanas más pequeñas y
menos pobladas su estrella en ascenso
morena le daba espera a participar en
muchos más festivales internacionales en
los próximos años
[Música]
y con esta buena música finalizamos este
capítulo de áfrica siete días y los
invitamos a continuar con más en nuestra
página web france24 puntocom que en seco
nosotros tenemos más información para
ustedes aquí en france 24
[Música]